- In the 18th century you start to have
significant interaction between
the English and the Indians,
especially in the East Indian Company.
And as part of that,
you start to have Western scholars start
to really study Sanskrit and the Vedas.
And as they do these,
it starts to really open up their mind
not just to the roots of Sanskrit
but also many of the Western languages
including English itself.
So, this is a quote in 1786
by the English philologist,
someone who studies written languages
especially from historical sources,
Sir William Jones.
He wrote, “The Sanskrit language,
whatever be its antiquity,
is of wonderful structure.
More perfect than the Greek,
more copious than the Latin,
and more exquisitely refine than either,
yet bearing to both of
them a stronger affinity
both in the roots of the verbs
and in the forms of grammar,
than could not possibly have
been produced by accident...”
Let me underline that.
“…than could not possibly have
been produced by accident.”
So he says there’s a lot of commonality
between the Sanskrit and Latin and Greek,
and it’s a strong affinity,
a strong connectedness
that could not have produced by accident.
So strong indeed,
that no philologer could examine all three
without believing them to have sprung
from some common source."
Let me underline that.
“Without believing them to have sprung
from some common source which,
perhaps no longer exists;
there is a similar reason
though not quit so forcible
for supposing that both
the Gothic and the Celtic,
though blended with a very different idiom
had the same origin with the Sanskrit;
and the old Persian might be
added to the same family.”
And so when they started
to study the Vedas
and look at the Sanskrit,
they started to realize
well maybe all of these
languages are connected.
And now modern day philologists
believe this very strongly
the more they have studied it.
Based on the connections and the grammar
and even the vocabulary and
the word structure themselves,
they now theorize that a parent language
of Sanskrit, Latin,
and the Germanic languages
and the Celtic languages
recall a language today
called Proto-Indo–European,
which is a lost language.
But we think that Sanskrit
is one of the oldest…
Is one of the oldest
evidences that we have
of that Proto-Indo-European Language.
Sanskrit as of course the parent language
has evolved in different parts of Indian
to languages like Hindi,
Bengali, and Punjabi.
Latin, which is also a dead language now,
has evolved into languages like
Spanish, Italian, and French.
And English
which is considered a Germanic
language structurally,
but has significant influence
from Latin and French,
they all come from that same
Proto-Indo-European root.
And just to get an appreciation
for why these philologist believe this,
and this is something when I first saw it,
really blew my mind a little bit.
I’ll show you some connections
between Sanskrit words,
and those of you who might be
Hindi, Bengali or Punjabi speakers,
or any of these North
Indian languages in India,
will see the connection to Sanskrit.
But what’s amazing is
how these words are connected to Latin
and many of the languages
derived from Latin.
Some of your Persian speakers
might recognize some,
some commonalities
and, most importantly,
the language that we
are speaking right now,
how to relate it to English.
And here is just a sample
of some Sanskrit words
that have an eerie resemblance
to both English and in
some cases Latin words.
Or many cases Latin words.
I’ve just given Latin in a few of them.
So the Sanskrit matr,
well in English we have mother
and in Latin we have mater.
And we also from Latin
in English via Latin,
we have words like maternity and maternal
all referring to the
same idea of motherhood.
And this general trend,
this t sound, matr or mater
becoming of more of a tha sound in English
and the Germanic languages
is a trend you’ll see over and over again.
In Sanskrit you have pithr,
in Latin you have pater,
and by way of Latin in modern English
we have words like paternity and paternal.
But going through the Germanic languages
you have once again that tha sound
becoming more of a tha sound.
And you also see this
pattern as you go from
this Proto-Indo-European,
this theoretical language,
and especially if you think
about relative to Sanskrit,
that you have the sound going from
a pa to a fa as you go to
the Germanic languages.
So pithr becomes, you
could say it farther.
And other words.
Na in Sanskrit…and those of you who speak
Hindi or Bengali would
recognize that of course,
and in English it is no.
Gau which is still,
it’s a Hindi word for cow,
in English it’s cow.
Gau , cow.
Naama,name.
In Latin nomen.
Dwar, door.
This one I thought was really interesting.
I didn’t know this until I started
looking it up a little bit.
Anamika is Sanskrit,
and it means anonymous.
Kaal, which is referring
to time in Sanskrit
and in modern Sanskrit drive languages
like Hindi and Bengali
it’s referring to references in time;
tomorrow, yesterday.
And in English you have calendar.
Naas and in something like,
in modern languages in the
sub-continent and you have naas,
and in English you have nose.
Loc in...in English
you have the prefix loc,
as in location or locate.
And then this is of
course a very nice one,
Sanskrit lubh, which means desire,
well in English we have the word love.
And this is just a sample,
I encourage you to look it up more,
you’ll be amazed by the connections
between Sanskrit and English.
And now I'm going to show you
what I think is one of the coolest,
because it isn’t just a
linguistic connection,
but it is also a,
I guess you could say
spiritual connection.
And this is the names
for the sky god from
several different traditions
So in the Vedas they
make reference to a god,
Dyauspithr, and it’s
literally referring to
Dyaus,
referring to sky.
And we already talked about Pithr
been the word for father.
So it’s referring to
this idea of sky father.
And some of you might be
getting goosebumps now
when you see where this is going.
Well, in Greek we have
a very similar word,
instead of Dyaus we have Zeus
and those are very similar words.
The spelling might be different,
but with the way it
comes out of your mouth
is very similar.
Dyaus, Dyaus,
Zeus,
instead of Pithr you have Pater,
once again you have sky,
you have sky father,
sky father right over here.
And this is another connection
that blew my mind.
It wasn’t obvious when I first saw it,
but Jupiter from Latin,
the Roman god,
you could use Jupiter.
This is once again instead
of Zeus you have Dyau,
instead of Pater you have Pitr.
So, instead of Dyauspitr you have Jupiter.
Dyauspitr, Jupiter.
These are very very similar words
even though the spelling seems different,
the way it comes out of your mouth
is very very very very very close.
And this is further
evidence for the closeness
between Sanskrit, between Greek,
and between Latin.
So once again, we have sky father.
And this of course an image of…
well it’s hard to tell whether
that’s Jupiter or Zeus.
I believe that is a picture of Jupiter.
And what’s also interesting is,
the Vedas sight
Dyauspitr
as the father of Indra.
Who’s considered the King of the gods.
One of the most significant,
if not the most significant
god in Hinduism.
And Indra is now in,
especially in the Vedas,
and this is the most spoken
about god in the Vedas,
Has many of the of the qualities
that we now in Greek and Roman traditions
associate with Zeus and Jupiter.
Indra is a sky god,
throws bolts of lightning.
Actually eerie similarity
with the Nordic god of Thor.
Where Nordic people were
also Indo-European people.
Where Indra he throws a hammer
and he defeats these monsters.
And all of these things,
very similar to Thor.
So hopefully these…
You know when I first learn this,
it just kind of made me realize
how connected the world is,
and it started to make me
start to look for patterns
where I hadn’t seen them before.
And it really shows
how these civilizations
that seemed very unconnected
might have,
and probably we do believe
emerged and (mumbles)
emerged from the same place.
Modern philologists and historian
believe that this Proto-Indo-European
might have been spoken by
people in the Caucuses.
The word Caucasian is referring
really to these people
from that Caucuses area there,
but we don’t know for sure.
And we believe that they migrated out.
And so when we talk
about the Germanic tribes
going into Northern Europe.
The Celtic tribes going into,
I guess you could say
North South Central Europe.
You could talk about the Italic,
the Latin tribes,
you could talk about the Greek tribes,
and you could also talk about the In…
you could also talk
about Indo-Aryan tribes
which eventually would settle into Persia
and into Northern India.
These we believe are all connected.